こんにちははじめ社長です今日はですね
実際にねあの磁石を使って僕の乳首が本当
にこっちがによるかどうかをね実際にやっ
てみようと思います嘘ですよ外寒いけど皆
さんどう過ごしでしょうか僕はモコ夏だし
たんで面白い付実は2つだったっていうな
ので部屋で撮る時はもうこういうちょっと
グクな感じでトラスティいただきます定義
で久しぶりの文房具コーナーです
はい文房具コーナー言うけれどほぼ喋り
出して頻繁にシャーペンが出るわけでも
半紙で他社便が僕の気になる奴かどう
かっていうのもわかんないし更新はそんな
にしないんですけどこれからもたまに
出そうとなんで文房具とかそのペースな人
は是非パッと見てくれたらありがたいです
a まああなたは boa
さあああっ私別にねぇ
アタリが来ました多分あたりだと言われて
おりますでは早速上げていきましょうああ
ああっ
中身は無事なのでしょうか
縁だ遊戯ついにやってまいりましたぜ皆
さんからのビルダーとですかっこいい
おそらくですけどかなり期待されています
先端が出て神よんがーどもー
守れないデルガード0.5さあペンシルで
ございますまたこう言うねなんか特許とか
出願しそうな感じですねも縦隔と先端に
負荷がかかりネットをれるますデルガード
システムが神よ守る芯が折れずに書き続け
られるっていうまさにとんでもない車店が
出たらしいでございますシンガー俺ないっ
ても画期的だね
俺のサーフィン普通で車ベンツ買ってたら
俺なんですよこう
こういう感じにこういう感じねちょっと
浸透型すぎるとで君すぎるとこう
秋ってなったんですね今回のデルガードは
その心配がないと言われています鈴木ね
ちょっとまず俺のスタメンはに強いて未だ
スタイがドクターグリップピュアホワイト
とそのぴスリムとスマッシュこれがね次
まで三種の神器俺がいしゃあペンに反響
ハイテク競争激化打倒クルトガ
クルトガなんだよなぁくれとかダサずっと
こうなんか
シャーペンの雑色を覆した感があって
やっぱりはどこもくると外の対抗商品を
出そうて頑張ってる感じなんですよね俺
くるとがあんま使わないんですよ神は回転
すればいいんですけど書くたびに芯咲きが
こうちょっとずれちゃってそのズレが
とても気に食いませんちなみに車種の b
で軽く動く書きたいんで尖った新作で書き
たいという気持ちもないんであんまり年先
とが来ると間に合うことを待ってますが
基本的にはドクターグリップで書いて腕が
疲れた時はアルファゲルちょっとしっかり
書きたいないってケアしましょ使います
ちなみに豆情報なんですけど中高生のクル
トガの認知度は100%らしいです常に
所有率は7割70%が来ると葉を使って
いるのかなんかみんな一緒で縫製がないね
俺が来るとパワーでちょっとあんまり使わ
ないで早速開けてみましょ位うわっ
やばいもうここから出れガードが始まって
いる
を
no なるほどなるほどかっこいい
ランいやこれ言っていいのかなぁ
ちょっとくるとラっぽい
まぁ見た目はね結構なんか来ると葉っぱ
ベルダーどのようなんか icom くる
とば槐っぽいんですよこんな感じですこれ
ここここが来るとがっぽい大蛇がペン先な
んですよ
とりあえず値段がで486円で結構お得な
んですよカラーバリエーションが青黒白
黄緑水色ピンクって結構豊富なんで結構
いろんな色があるんでなんか好きな色が
見つかりそうですねほんとに特徴がね筆記
つのあらゆる角度のどんなに強い筆圧から
も折れないように身を守るということで
折れないらしいですよほんとなぁスカ折っ
ちゃうよ僕折っちゃうよなぜ世界はず
らしいですね折れない心が折れない喋って
いう大
俺ない俺ない気がするこれはちょっと暑い
んじゃないですかどっちで俺ねー
なにこれなんか
折ろうとしたら折ろうとしたらなんか2が
下がってくるんですよ
ちょっとな説明しづらいはへこれをれない
の
は月で月で折れないん
新も取り出してみようあ
神様出し過ぎたら俺ますただ常識の範囲の
芯の長さだとまずはおりませんこれぐらい
のシーンだと売れないんですよ
あなんでもないけどなんかねおれオレ様と
したら
実験が下がってくるんだろう
でもちゃんと写真はもどって来るという
キュッってこれ俺ねーわ
使えるこれを支える it 技でですねを
レンズじゃないな振ってデルガドですね
本当に芯が折れないんで思いっきり強く
書いちゃう人とかはすごいいいと思います
本当に違いにこのシャーペンが最高って
ことは言えないんですけどまぁで
lugano よかったら遊んで受験生の
人とか勉強しなきゃいけない人とかさ
結構文房具でたい武器もちろん持つ様が
変わるんで俺ないシャーペン出るかどう
どうでしょうか
図研製
をれるなよ気持ちも
恥ずかしい